tonight we start in ukraine where it is
a winter on fire missiles are raining
down on the country as russian forces
push deeper and deeper inside closing in
on the capital vladimir putin has his
eyes set on kiev and reports say it
could fall by this weekend
while the death toll rises by the minute
fox news correspondent trey yingst is
live from kiev ukraine with the very
latest
jesse good evening we're getting some
new numbers from ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky who said tonight that
137 ukrainians have been killed since
this uptick in violence began and this
larger russian invasion into sovereign
ukrainian territory we do know at this
hour the russians are continuing their
air and ground campaign against a number
of ukrainian positions across the
country there were some key battles
today for an airfield just outside the
capital of kiev and additionally over
some land north of the ukrainian capital
in chernobyl we understand in chernobyl
russian forces were able to push forward
and
ultimately
retain that land which is significant
because that will give them a straight
shot to the ukrainian capital on the
airfield that's close to where we're
standing now just about a 40 minute
drive from here
initially the russians used attack
helicopters to take over the airfield
but tonight we are learning from the
ukrainian defense ministry that they
were able to counter attack and
ultimately get that airstrip back a
significant win for a a battle that
could have really changed the entire
situation here allowing the russians to
bring in more equipment at that airfield
very close to the capitol one thing to
note here ukrainian president zielinski
has ordered the general mobilization of
forces in ukraine this means that any
military-aged man 18 to 60 must stay and
fight on behalf of the country
additionally ukraine is still under
martial law at this hour and the
president is urging people not to go to
the streets claiming that russian
saboteurs have actually made their way
into the capital and will attempt to
disrupt the flow and preparation of
forces here as they prepare for the
possibility of russian troops breaching
the city jesse trey you say the
ukrainian government is arming the
citizens and they're encouraging them to
fight for their country what is your
sense of
that passion to fight to the death to
save ukraine by the people there
the interior minister announced today
more than ten thousand weapons were
being handed out to civilians we're also
seeing local media reports tonight
indicating that more weapons will be
handed out to people in public squares
tomorrow a big indicator of what is to
come there's a real sense here that if
those russian troops make it into the
ukrainian capital a city with a
population of three million people it
will not be an easy fight it will be
quite bloody we understand because
everyone that we have talked to who is
staying in ukraine they say they will
stay and they will fight on behalf of
their country so if the weapons are
there and the forces the enemy target in
front of them certainly we will see
battles in the streets here and it is
something to look out for as the
ukrainian military will have to keep
pulling back from their positions if
they get overrun by russian troops here
in ukraine jesse
stay safe trey thanks so much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else